hey everyone welcome to yessi tv where
we talk about minimalism is more than
just decluttering physical items from
your life
if you guys have subscribed before i
want to first of all take this time to
apologize
that i have not been posting content in
a while and i kind of just wanted to let
you know what's been going on
so i am currently seven months pregnant
very thankful and happy to have a baby
boy on the way
but i've had a few health issues that
came up unexpectedly
and a few tests that came out abnormal
nothing major thankfully baby's okay
but i do need some more closer checkup
and so i've been taking the time to just
take care of my health more
and baby's health of course i've been
away for a little bit but i do hope to
be able to post a little bit more
frequently
moving onward but i thank you so much
for watching and if you like this video
please thumbs it up
and if not then give it a thumbs down
but please give me some feedback because
that helps as well
so let's get on with the video in a
previous video i shared with you 25
reusable items that you could swap out
for that save you money
today i'm actually here to show you 25
more
items because i don't know about you but
i like to save the environment
save my health and save money have you
ever had to replace a rug because it's
gotten so worn out or just plain nasty
over time
we decided to invest in washable rugs
instead when we moved into our new home
and i'm so glad that we did
in our previous home i got the great
idea to get a
white fuzzy rug in the living room of
all places and i loved it for about a
month
until i realized how hard it was to
clean the thing
and when i looked into the price to be
able to rent a machine to have it
professionally cleaned
the price just was not worth it next up
washable shower curtains this was a
simple swap that has saved me so much
headache since i bought it about a year
ago
and i decided to buy it for two main
reasons number one i
hated constantly having to work so hard
to scrub the heck out of these plastic
liners that always seem to get just
nasty right away and number two
i realized and learned that the
chemicals inside the plastic
shower curtain liners can actually
harbor toxic chemicals that combine with
the hot water
mix into the mist and the vapor that you
breathe in when you're taking a shower
so they can actually be harmful for you
especially the ones that contain pvc in
them
next up baby food pouches
i admit i myself am guilty of having
purchased these disposable snack pouches
because
they have this awesome convenience
that's just so easy to grab and go when
you're out on the run
but they do have a replaceable option or
reusable option excuse me
that you can use there's tons of cute
options out there
so if you're willing to blend up some
fruit or puree some veggies
you might want to consider this one to
still have that convenience of having
the
food pouch without having that extra
waste
and extra expense next up washable
earplugs
we all know that sleep is important but
for me earplugs are a
must for sleep but even if you do yard
work for example
you know that your ears can get pretty
nasty pretty quick
same as your ear plugs so i decided to
buy some washable silicone earplugs and
i'm happy that i did because
obviously they work but now i have the
benefit that i don't have to have these
packs
of earplugs in my home just taking up
space as well
earplugs can also harbor bacteria if you
reuse them which i did not know this and
i have done this before
so now we have the added bonus that we
can just wash them and reuse them as
needed
the particular kind that we purchased
has one small container that we can keep
in our shed for yard work
purposes and then i can keep this little
guy by my nightstand and then just wash
it when needed
[Music]
next up rain barrels these were actually
gifted to
us i believe they come from home depot
but there are many other varieties out
there
they basically collect rain water and
have a spigot to where you can connect
your hose to
you can use it for the garden or like us
we have chickens and for the most part
they run free
but we do put out water for them so this
will be a good alternative that will be
sustainable for us
next up plants that can be propagated
okay can anyone relate to me here i love
plants but i just always find a way to
kill them
let me know in the comments how good are
you with house plants
a few years back i learned about common
toxic chemicals that we have in our home
and so i started bringing more air
purifying plants into our home as
a way to clean the air that we breathe
according to nasa it is recommended that
you have
one air purifying plant for every
hundred square feet of space that you
have in your home
so in the process of trying to bring
more plants into the home i
inevitably killed a couple here and
there and so i started bringing more
plants that were easily
propagatable is it propagatable
easily propagateable and basically what
this means
is that you just take a clipping of the
plant and then
use that put it in either water or soil
and replant it as a new plant that will
grow
i actually grew this pothos from a
bigger plant here
and basically all that i did was cut one
leaf put it in water until the roots
grew in and then replanted it
i'm also doing this with a snake plant
right now but snake plant takes a lot
longer
but if you like plants and you just
somehow keep killing them
then maybe look into plants that you can
easily propagate that way you don't have
to keep
buying new plants and you're cleaning
the air that you breathe
cloth potty training underwear in this
one you will of course save money if you
just
flat out don't buy these and just buy
regular underwear for your kids or your
toddlers
but if you are going to spend money on
these cases and cases
of the disposable training underwear
then you might want to consider this
some kinds and some brands have liners
that still allow the child to feel the
wetness so that they
they start to learn that it's a
different feeling but they also
kind of keep the goods built in there so
that it saves your sanity as well
because these items add up quickly
up next reusable erasable notebook
in my search to find diversified items
for this list i came across the rocket
book and i admit i got really nerdy
excited about this one because i had
never heard about it
it's basically a notebook that comes in
different colors and different sizes
and you can write on it and then it
gives you the option to scan in the
information to save it onto an
app that you can then erase the notebook
and use it again
genius next up soap nuts
this item is not one that lasts forever
but it definitely does last longer than
average detergent does the way that i
started using this was really just as a
trial
to see what the hype was all about and
to test it out and see if it really
works
i've been using them for a few months
now and if you have not heard of these
things before they're basically nuts
that when they come into contact with
water they release chemicals called
saponins
and these are what lather your clothing
and get them clean
they're biodegradable and eco-friendly
the particular brand that i purchased
comes with a smaller baggie that you
basically put in about four to six of
these little guys depending on how much
you're washing
into a little baggie tie it up put it in
your washing machine as you're washing
your cycle
and you can actually reuse these several
times and you'll start to tell once they
break apart
start breaking down that they're not
really any good anymore
but you can reuse them i've used them
like five or six times per baggie
so i've actually washed my clothing my
husband's work clothes my toddler's
clothes with these little guys
as a trial with everything just to see
how well they work
and i do notice that my clothing comes
out clean but if you
are looking for stain removal like
whitening
or if you're looking for something
that's scented that smells good
this is not going to be your best friend
because they are non
they're non-scented so if you don't
really
care about stain or whitening abilities
of your detergent
or the smell of your detergent these
might be a great option for you they
last a lot longer i've had this bag for
about two months now
and a bonus tip if you do want your
laundry to smell good but you don't want
to harm the environment or your health
with toxic chemicals and softeners
then what you can do is use epsom salts
with essential oils and not only does
this make your clothing
softer but it makes it smell so good as
well if you guys are interested in a
video on
non-toxic chemicals um or non-toxic
alternatives that you can use in your
home then perhaps i can make a video on
that
next up reusable lint roller i don't
really care much about the removal of
lint but if lint bothers you then this
might be a good option for you it's
basically sticky
and you can use it again by washing it
with soap and water
next up washable doggy pads
i do not have a dog so i cannot give you
first hand experience here but these
things have
great reviews so considering the price
of
one disposable pack these might be worth
considering
nylon dog poop bag
okay i'm not saying i would personally
use this but if you're tired of
constantly buying disposable doggy bags
or you just want to be eco-friendly this
option is out there you basically
grab the bag and take the poop with you
to flush
and you're supposed to wash this thing i
don't know
i cloth diaper my babies but it just to
me this is different what do you guys
think would you do this or have you ever
heard of this before
let me know in the comments next up
period panties
this is another one that i do not see
myself using the idea is just not
convincing to me
but they do have great reviews online so
it might be something that you might
like
personally i like my menstrual cups and
my cloth pads which i have mentioned in
my previous video
so i can link them in the description or
you can watch that other video to learn
more about those
next up reusable air fresheners
these things are made with activated
bamboo charcoal which is a natural air
purifier
that absorbs and removes odors without
using chemicals
they can be used for up to two years and
basically what you do is about once a
month you place them out in the sun so
that the sun
will naturally absorb the moisture and
rejuvenate the charcoal
but i don't know i'm too addicted to
essential oils to try this one out
next stainless steel ear wax cleaner
if you find yourself constantly buying
boxes of q-tips
then this might be a good option for you
it's basically just a metal that you can
wash and reuse
and if you have a lot of earwax buildup
then this might be a space saving option
for you as well
up next magnetic eyelash extensions
i admit this is probably not something
that i would ever buy for myself but
it's definitely on my wish list
my makeup collection has definitely
decreased since i came across minimalism
this is my makeup bag it's everything
that i own and it all fits in one little
baggie
but i used to have a big makeup case
that had the drawers that opened out
and eyelash extensions were definitely
always in stock
but i gave it up for several reasons the
chemicals that you use to put on the
eyelash extensions are harmful for your
body as well
and i found that when i would rip them
off it would tear off my natural lashes
which i don't want to ruin my natural
beauty
to have fake beauty put on it so i
stopped using those
but if you guys still like your eyelash
extensions and you
tired of buying new ones then perhaps
look into this one next up
silicone travel bottles i mean it could
be silicone it could be whatever other
kind of material you like
but if you constantly travel and you
find yourself going to the travel size
section to buy your travel size
toiletries
stop that you are spending so much more
money
per ounce on all of these items when you
can just buy
one little pack that you can reuse and
use your own items from home
every single time you travel next up
silicone baking cups
if you love to bake and you constantly
find yourself buying the paper or the
metal
cupcake cups then these might be a good
option for you you basically wash them
and
they're good as new to use plus they're
really cute
silicone lids in my previous video i
mentioned
beeswax paper as an alternative to cling
wrap and these basically have
the benefit that they can mold to
basically any shape
but they do wear over time silicone lids
are able to stretch over your containers
or your food to keep them fresher for
longer which can save you money in the
food waste department
next up stackable lunch trays stackable
lunch trays are kind of the replacement
for paper plates
so if you constantly find yourself
having parties or large gatherings then
perhaps you can consider investing
in a set that you can reuse instead of
constantly buying new ones this is kind
of more of like an eco-friendlier
version
because i don't know that it simplifies
your life it's probably if anything can
make you
spend more time to clean up and gather
all of the supplies again
but it's an option out there for you and
along with that there are reusable
red party cups surely you've seen
the iconic red party cups there is a
reusable option that's thicker
and sturdier so that you can wash and
reuse again we personally have a lot of
stainless steel cups which i find to be
more durable
and just more aesthetically pleasing but
they are stackable so they don't take up
a whole lot of room
in our cabinet and when we have people
over we don't have to keep
buying the disposable cups so if you're
interested in those
i can link them in the description up
next cloth piping bags
i used to do a lot of baking and i would
constantly buy the plastic
little piping bags and they do have a
reusable option i don't really bake
anymore so this isn't really necessary
for me but if this is you
then you could look into this as an
option next up silicone
scrubbing brush okay this one's not that
exciting it's basically a silicone brush
that you can use
as a bottle brush instead of the little
fiber ones that you keep constantly
replacing
and last but not least washable food
hugger or food saver
these are a bit similar to the silicone
stretch lids
but they basically are smaller in size
they're stackable
and they're more geared towards smaller
items such as
limes or avocados things that go bad
more often
that way they conform to the shape of
that item and you save le
money on food waste that's it for this
video i thank you so much for watching
it's been really good to be back here
with you
if you like this video thumbs it up and
subscribe so that you won't miss out on
my next videos
can't wait to hear from you bye
okay as i was counting this list i
realized that there are only 24
items on this list so i'm gonna give you
some homework
how about you share with me one reusable
item that has saved you money
leave it in the comments below